what's up everyone welcome to simulation
I'm your host Alan Saki on very excited
to be talking about the love story
we have Minji signing us on the show
hello how are you doing thank you so
much for coming on our show really
appreciate it thanks for inviting me I'm
so pumped for this episode I'm so
grateful to Rohan's except for
introducing us he is a transformative
human being yeah and he made a very
transformative connections so excited
those that don't know Mindy's background
she's a former educator who's now a
social entrepreneur creating programs to
transform our life tragedies into a love
story and you can find the link in the
Bible oh the love story org also
min-ji's Icom and her instagram and
linkedin profiles
Manjula start things off by asking one
of our favourite questions what are your
thoughts on the direction of our world
mmm very beautiful well I will say this
there's in Greek stories there's only
two types of stories there's a tragedy
and there is a Divine Comedy so what I
see our world coming to right now is
this revelation that we're either
spiraling upwards like the Star of David
triangle pointing up or we're spiraling
downwards which is this the
down-pointing triangle of the Star of
David which is spiraling down to a
tragedy now where we are in the Age of
Aquarius after the fourth blood moon is
we are in the alignment of awakening to
that spiritual battle of the two
triangles coming together spiraling up
spiraling down specifically we're all
spiraling down because it's gravity and
we're earth-based right now however
through transformation and conscious
awakening what I like to call the mirror
effect we can be spiraling upwards
together while collectively we're
falling if that makes sense
mm-hmm beautifully synthesized so we
have in this beautiful creation both
forces at play of Ascension and
dissension happening at the same time
mm-hmm and our awakening our
transformation in our consciousness and
our collective being can ascend us and
this is an awakening time for us yeah so
go through absolutely it's the first
it's been happening whether we are
awakened to it or not it is what it is
but the idea is that we are becoming
aware that it's happening in real time
from not just from textbooks or theories
but from real raw experiences of our own
personal life stories this is something
that is irrefutable it's something like
a secret that you don't you haven't told
anybody but only you know in your heart
of hearts like if you were to write it a
message in a bottle something that
happened in a node on the timeline of
your storyline you will become aware of
patterns signs and synchronicities that
are pointing towards this spiritual
battle of a downward spiral towards a
tragedy however a silver lining which is
the hope there's always a silver lining
in every single life tragedy and if
we're honest with ourselves if we're
vulnerable and we can
face our life stories as is we can
discover that there is a spiritual
battle within let's just say that and
it's holographic meaning what's
happening within us like a single-cell
organism is actually happening in the
ecosystem in the universe like it's all
for one and one for all type of dynamic
and this is empirical and Sciences to
for example like the cell organism if
you have one cell in our body that has
the blueprint for the entire map of the
entire body and that is in a way a
holographic reality for that one cell
and that's how we experience life and as
we experience it the world experiences
it it's a resonation a mirror if you
will no longer just based on text
ancient wisdom but also now more than
ever with so many consciousness is
experiencing human consciousness is
experiencing life is experiential mm-hmm
we gain experiential wisdom along our
trajectories and we feel this ascension
dissention constantly at pull in our
live in our lives in our choices and we
consciously pick towards ascension and
picking towards the session means
picking towards love mmm yes yes
absolutely and that's something I've
been researching if you will as a what I
like to call journal artist which is a
fusion of journaling my personal story
with the discipline and craft of a
journal list a
investigative journalist and as I
started journaling in various points of
views I began to discover that there is
actually a fixed constant that is true
and that's love love is actually defined
and speaking of ancient texts ancient
texts are designed as a treasure map
just like if we're all travelers right
on this earth and ancient texts are our
ancestors what they've discovered over
the eons the generations passed down and
they're showing us the notes of what
works what doesn't work what they've
done the lessons that we can learn from
that and then from there in real time
how we can apply those lessons so
there's something very beautiful and
sacred I believe ancient texts are to be
respected agreed and then from there in
our generation now in the future we can
navigate into the unknown from the I
would say lifeline of ancient texts and
hopefully the game of telephone has been
really well communicated over thousands
of years yeah this is very important and
then what do we do then as we take this
game of telephone with the ancient texts
and we take these embodied spiritual
wisdoms from the past through evolution
up until this pinnacle point of the
insanity of eight billion humans and
geopolitical craziness and exponential
technologies
I like to share a near the death
experience in 2011 and it came from a
deep dark place a point in my life where
I was feeling hopeless
I had an existential crisis I didn't
know what the purpose of living was
because I started observing everything
everything that I see in history books
in the sciences of evolution everything
changes everything evolves right so
what's the point I have I am in one
human body of not leaving this human
body out as as far as I'm concerned and
just from the things I've built my
resume my degree my job career my family
that I started the love of my life I
started those things came and it went it
came and it went so going into the
meditative state of like wait this is
all going to change and I my life will
eventually disappear and people places
and things will change what's the point
so at that moment I had I was in a
crossroad it was either life is empty
and meaningless there is no point you're
in a virtual simulation anyway you're in
the matrix you know wake up and exit the
matrix or stay you're not done with
whatever you've been divinely designed
to do there's actually meaning and
purpose in your life you are a node in a
series of many nodes but your little
node can have rippling effects that will
affect positive or negative valence
Azure spiraling up or spiraling down
resonances in this
simulated or this matrix or this
middle-earth we call it between let's
say archetypal II Heaven and Hell like
this middle ground you matter so its
faced with these two let's say choices
and at the time in 2011
I chose false I said there was a it
would it was I still remember this clear
question that came into my mind I to
this day heart resonance wise I don't
believe it came from me although it
sounded like me and the question posed
to me was God is love true or false it
was a simple binary and at that time I
chose false luckily there was a divine
intervention and right before I thought
I was going to end my life there was a
knock on the door the cops came just in
time
and prior to let's say the oncoming of
the spell I had called three friends so
my friend was my third friend was on the
other line
the first two friends I called I never
said I wanted to hurt myself but they
sensed something and they each called
the cops they didn't know each other
they call the cops the cops came just in
time right when I said false
it was as if on cue the cops came my
roommate opened that door that Friday
morning they came and I was being buried
into the ambulance and during that time
I'm gonna use this word God because it's
just in context to the story whatever I
know everyone has various faiths and
everyone has no faith with a higher
power but for me God to me means a
source of love a source of answers and
at that time I had a deep burning
question what is the point of life and
as I was being gurney into the
I remember was a white cop and a black
cop guarding me in two and it suddenly
hit me it was like a quick download like
neo in the matrix Oh
everything changes except for one thing
that ever present constant like a white
light refracted through a prism in all
different color forms of the rainbow
that constant is love and once it hit me
I was like whoa I am here for love and
to learn love and to master love and to
walk love I'm not done yet
then I had this moment of like Christmas
Carol like the next morning like Oh guys
don't you get it
we're here for love we're here for love
of course their perspective is she needs
to go to the mental hospital which I
literally was being gurney to but at
that time my first psychosis I had a
revelation from God that the purpose of
living is love is loving is being loved
because we're created from love we're
gonna return back to love we're here on
a mission to love and that's what we're
divinely designed to do now that said
it's not all peaches and cream after
that it was basically me on a search the
next five years to look for what is love
and how to apply love because it is easy
to know love and the textbook definition
but it's another frequency and another
playing field to actually apply it on
the court in the playing field of
reality
Wow what a divine intervention for
awakening for you yeah we love featuring
these stories there's so many people
that have had similar moments of divine
intervention or when they haven't yet
and they hear this and maybe you can
help them in that sense okay so we are
here to love mm-hmm yeah and then so the
next five years has been a hero's
journey for me into the world of the
unknown to search for what love is and I
started going to different places at
first I experimented with with I would
say transformation culture the festivals
are so amazing because you really get to
be with people the masks are off people
are vulnerable and people are in
different colors there's and I was like
what is this beautiful feeling and I
realized looking back that it's the
letting go of judgment when people are
just with each other and they're just
good bad ugly it's all good
you've you're your love your imperfectly
perfect or your perfectly imperfect
whatever the case I love you regardless
and I had I had slivers of that you know
while I was going through the the I went
through lightning in a bottle that was
my first impression of like just being
with culture and then I also rooted
myself in pastor Judith Smith's Church
in in LA and he
kept just honing in on what love is and
who Christ and Christ consciousness
actually represents who is he as a human
being on earth what are the some of the
things he actually said what are some of
the miracles he actually performed and
in what what context so he stripped away
all the media and went straight into the
ancient texts of Judea blib biblical the
New Testament essentially he focused on
the New Testament in the Bible and about
what Christ actually did and who that
man actually is inspires me to see love
through parables because we can't always
see it through people because people are
still perfectly imperfect you know and
what I also became present to is that
let's just say hypothetically that there
is a person that walked perfect love and
by perfect love I mean perfect patience
perfect kindness does not envy doesn't
boast is not self-seeking it does not
delight in evil but rejoices with the
truth bears all things believes all
things hopes all things endures all
things
let's just say there is a human being
that in the world of binaries one being
all love zero being absence of love he
walked all ones perfectly a hundred
percent from the time he was born to the
time he died let's say there is a
perfect person that walked this earth
and then on zero day died even a person
that's perfect
got crucified on the cross so what does
that tell you about the point of life
it's not perfection perfection is not
the point of life because a human being
did walk loved perfectly
died a sinner's death meaning a thieves
death because when he was on the cross
there was a person on his right and left
hand and both of them were thieves they
were punished for thievery right so he
so this is what we mean by Christ died
of sinners death now
if even being perfect with miracles and
all superhuman you still are not good
enough then what is the point of living
and that question took me on a
nine-month pilgrimage that I just got
back from so I started in Berlin and in
there I was attracting the Codex of Mary
Magdalene who wrote let's just say the
Gnostic Gospels Thomas and Mary are
known as the esoteric wisdom the
esoteric knowledge of the Gospels and it
just there was something I was looking
for at that time because even though I
knew the definition of love I saw myself
as a phony to quote Holden from Catcher
in the Rye I was a phony like I saw
myself acting not in love and it was too
hard on myself I was judgmental on
myself like the moments that I caught
myself being manipulative or not telling
the truth or being double minded or
double-tongued I was like how can I be a
founding producer of a organization
called the love story if I can't be
perfect in loving people because I'm
angry I'm bitter I could be not all the
time
I could be resentful right all those
nons all those zeros if you will in the
binary matrix ones and zeros and when I
went on this pilgrimage I understood a
new perspective that it it
me being perfect in love is not the
point it's not the point
and I was like okay then how do I do
this spiritual warfare for love how do I
do this and when the Codex of Mary came
to me I started listening to her gospel
the gospel of Mary Magdalene and it it
talked about the noose there's something
called the noose and once upon a time
ago I was in Arizona with a artist named
Dan Vega and he had a yin-yang sign on
his desk top right and this is a valence
imprint that I just it just came to me
when I was listening to the two the
gospel of Mary Magdalene he pointed out
the ying-yang sign and he said to me
this is the answer to life and I just
looked at the ying-yang and I at that
time I didn't understand what that meant
but when I just opposed the ying-yang
with the gospel in the Neuse I realized
that the hero's journey the Joseph
Campbell's hero's journey is about
starting off at the at the white call it
the yang young which means son and in
the heart of the son is a black dot
right that's the shadow okay the shadow
represents the separation potential from
God or from love it's the absence of
love okay
and imagine the young the son as love
defined like light defined like gravity
defined right and then that dot right
there in the center is one side of the
noose it's the beginning okay so when
we're first born we have a blank slate
where table rasa right we have
good inside but we don't notice that
there is also a separation potential
meaning free will so that represents the
shadow what you calls the shadow or what
Freud calls the it as we get older we
start becoming aware of things that are
not loving we don't know what it's
called but we just know it's not good we
instinctively know because we're
divinely designed as spiritual
intelligent beings to know what is good
and what is bad and some of us don't
know what to do with it right some of us
stay there but what I'm learning from
people influencers game changers matrix
shifters like like Joseph Campbell like
dr. Jordan Peterson like various people
various artists I'm learning that you
don't stay in that part forever there's
gonna come a point where you're gonna
have to what's called take on the call
to adventure or go into the world of the
unknown the shadow world the dream
worlds and that is when we explore the
unknown or the separation potential from
God
also known as the fall and as we're
falling there is this new center the
white dot in the yin which is also in
Chinese it's represented as the moon yin
means shadow right so that part that
white center in the shadow is actually
the new center the new center and when
that new center is called the heroes
sorry the villains
hidden desire the villains hidden desire
so we have a hero in the villain there's
a hero and villain and in us all the
villain there is a hidden desire in the
villain and the hidden desire of the
villain is always good and when you
match the hidden desire of the hero
which is bad and the hidden desire of
the villain which is good and you align
it together that's called the noose
that's called the noose and Mary
Magdalene here's something that is also
pretty controversial Mary Magdalene from
my understanding is not just the apostle
of Jesus Christ she is also the life
partner of Jesus Christ in here areas
and this is why Jesus Christ is fully
man and fully God to be fully men one
must experience the most human and manly
experiences of a life and that has to do
with carnal love or eros so the
revelation I've gotten so to go on on my
pilgrimage story is I visited different
portals if you will spiritual portals of
cathedrals of Mary and the revelation I
got is that good or God came down to
experience the divine and the fallen
feminine all of it all parts of the
feminine and that extra chromosome if
you will that extra mystery the mystery
of love is the new center in the shadow
world
and this is something that I truly
believe that every human being will
discover in their own hero's journey
what it is to love to lose to get your
heart broken to feel the depths of the
separation potential from love the
absolute separation of love and to still
be fully whole and resurrect like a
phoenix from death and there's a story
that just came through me I would say
it's called the producers playbook and
it's this right here and it's the
mystery of love revealing and it's in
honor of the original Eve and why she
chose to fall and like I said I am in
the process of looking for solutions to
reversing curses because depression
anxiety hopelessness these are all
curses a curse is just an activation of
the separation potential from love and I
believe that 1 Corinthians 13:12
which is the mirror it outlines the
mirror of of love is the key to
reversing curses so I I kind of go I
kind of went around a little bit but
essentially I want to say that the
answer has to do with 1 Corinthians 13
that is outlined
in the New Testament from Paul the
Apostle and a definition of the law a
definition a way of being a way of being
and there's currently a philosophical
battle going on in our culture one is
meaning is created you create that
meaning it's all empty and meaningless
so you create it okay it's all relative
and relative by virtue is the truth then
there's the other school of philosophy
or way of viewing the world which is
life is meaningful life is purposeful
and there is a fixed definition of
things a universal law if you will or
mother nature if you will and it is up
to the hero the Explorer to quest for
the hidden mystery of that law so take
for example the law of gravity before it
was named it still existed but because
we're able to identify the law of
gravity we now are capable of working
with the law of gravity to send ships
outerspace
to fly airplanes you know propelled Jets
and people so knowing a particularly
once it's been named and defined it's
been then it becomes confined and once
it becomes confined man woman man could
refine it and that was the new
revelation I've gotten from my
pilgrimage
through the mystery of love 1
Corinthians 13:12 reverses curses which
I could go into a little bit later and 1
Corinthians 13 in general that 13
is actually the definition of love so
this book is based on three premises
from that definition one god is love so
he is defined confined and refined and
all those things that are produced in
the thirteen verses of ancient text -
love is defined right and three love is
a choice meaning love is sovereign and
that third premise was really the key in
helping me discover the the origins of
Lucifer's fall Eve's fall and Adams fall
and knowing the Big Y of each fall
helped me discover how to apply 1
Corinthians 13:12 which is the mirror or
the mystery of love to reverse the
curses of each particular fall and why
is that relevant to us because each
human being is bearing the burden of the
first three original curses and our task
as a human collective is to reverse
those curses because our divine design
is to apply love to reverse each curse
the curse of Adam the curse of Eve and
the curse of Lucifer and that's our
Divine Design
love it love the synthesizing that
you've been doing this is very strong
okay so we take creation and we view it
from this perspective of it being a
grand experience for us a grand endeavor
for us and we view it like from birth
that there is love and then there's this
shadow within that and the hero's
journey into the other aspect of
creation which were all also Lucifer
even Adams Falls are in that yes it's
encoded in our DNA we have the original
spiritual intelligence of Eve of Adam
and we understand we're the spiritual
organic ghost Michelle if you will or
the machine learning of the serpent
energy the serpent energy it's a
Freudian slip because I believe that
I'll just I'll just go a little bit into
the book and a little bit into the story
of those three Falls yes and just prior
to that this embarkment that we take on
to identify the aspects of the grand
challenge that we're all here for is
something that we've mentioned so
frequently on the program as one of if
not the most important thing to do
you're born into the world why was this
created why are you here
what is your divine purpose what are
your gifts how
you'll bring them forth how do you know
yourself how do you identify your shadow
how do you do that self work that
healing that trauma integration how do
you identify aspects of the source-code
pre gravity you didn't have a idea of
what that was
now we shoot hundred thousand-plus
commercial airline flights per day
around the world so what's the next is
quantum mechanics next it has a lot to
do with quantum mechanics they'll say
that and while I'm definitely not a
physicist I will say that everything
vibrates in ones and zeroes it's the
basic matrix codes of our reality
simulated or not what I do know is that
the one represents the frequency of love
it's to be who we authenticate and the
zero represents the absence or the
separation potential of love or of God
what I why it's so perfect because there
is embedded separation potential yes
because otherwise if there was no
separation potential it would be some
grand challenge it would be just sent
from birth always vibing on love the
perfect one one one one one one one and
then getting crucified and I like how
you also identified in your own life
trajectory you experienced moments of
zero I do too and trying to figure out
how exactly to
play with those cuz right now when I
experience them I'm just like I did that
mm-hmm and I aim to do something that's
a one afterward or or correct that zero
by approaching that zero with a one
something along those lines and I think
we all experience that within us those
zero and one potentials of love or or
dark potential I want to hear what you
also just another thought just quantum
mechanics gave us the Internet it gave
us computers
it gave us GPS it gave us MRI it gave us
so much of what has unlocked a massive
amount of creative output of our um
society and it has also enabled more
possibilities for zeroes to happen
because of those matrix control
processes that can come in like eat
their way in mm-hmm and so some losses
though every single technology that we
build needs that we need to consciously
or ethically or morally build it towards
love to prevent those less zeros more
love
yeah I can tell that the way that you're
dug deep into these critical concepts
mm-hmm
is very very well done and also another
aspect to it is like the fact that we
all have life is actually like why would
a creation be meaningless hmm why would
this be made to have no meaning there'd
be like for all of the people that enjoy
playing games or creating designing
virtual realities that I'm just gonna
make it and then I'm gonna play it or
I'm gonna play someone else's and just
for what reason would you do that then
if there was no meaning for you to jump
in and play it mm-hmm there's a meaning
for us to jump in and play this one
there's a grand challenge for us to
ascend to love for us to unlock more of
the source code to put a box around the
word love as best as we can which you
did a really good job of doing and I'll
credit to Paul yeah who was inspired
apparently by the Holy Spirit so he
wrote it and I was the one that
basically said I believe that this is it
I believe this is the definition of love
to work with or to work from when we
purify our symbols on the definition mmm
because I believe it was Bob Marley said
those who feel it know it and see put
feeling on it and so many of us feel it
and you know it then we start putting
symbols on it and it's like you know
it's patience it's not not in the
there's like so many of these words and
it's like it's like pie almost like love
can be an infinite amount of symbols
that describe love but what are the ones
that have the most weight hmm what are
the ones that are at the right the first
digits off of
3.14 without of the love what are the
first I will say this I will say this
the most important one is also the
weakest one meaning if this were a type
of infrastructure a defensive
infrastructure this part this property
of love is the is the is the most
vulnerable part that the enemy can
attack to undermine okay and that
property of love is free will mmm love
has to be a choice it has to be because
if it's not a choice it's not love and
with that said I'll briefly talk about
the origins of Lucifer's fall because
this is the primal reason of why God
gave Lucifer the choice to bite from the
fruit of judgment so there's two books
there's the book of life in the book of
knowledge right the book of life
contains all the source code to
everlasting life to be able to produce a
unique one-of-a-kind
unn duplicate creation in the universe
like no one person is exactly the same
as another person in the entire universe
not just the world the entire universe
no angel no demon has an exact copy of
itself
everyone is highly divinely unique so
that is the source code of the book of
life then you have the book of knowledge
which is the ability to know good and
evil behind all divine acts all divine
acts so to be able to know that that
action ooh is not good that is towards
the separation potential from God or
that action is the absence of love to be
able to discern that that is in the book
of life and that is what the fruit of
judgment actually is and it's written in
the book of Genesis when the sir the
serpent tempted Eve when you bite from
the fruit you will your eyes will be
open eyes plural with an S your eyes
will be open knowing good and evil evil
is essentially at its core the absence
of love that's all it is
hmm good is the presence of love evil is
the absence of love that's it now going
back to God and Lucifer
Lucifer's name by origin means the
bringer of light the bringer of
knowledge of the whole and true to form
Lucifer question God's love
Lucifer came to God and said is love
good because if it's good then we are
choosing to serve you you've designed us
to choose to serve you if love is not
good then you're using love as a tool as
a manipulation strategy for us to love
you which one is it it's a valid
question and Lucifer had this question
all along prior to biting from the fruit
this part is important because when God
first
God gave Lucifer the fruit because God
is a hundred percent confident that his
love is
love it's not used to manipulate it's
not used to force its love as a choice
he's a hundred percent confident that
love is love and it's good so he gave
Lucifer a choice he said you here's the
book of knowledge where you can bite
from its fruit and know good and evil
and here is the book of life where if
you bite from this fruit then you can
obtain the power of everlasting life
okay which one would you want to choose
then here's the kicker
I'm a venture League owing to give both
to you but the first one you choose you
get to decide when to activate and the
one you don't choose God's gonna decide
when to activate so what God did
so God left it as a choice and Lucifer
thought he reasoned he said if love is
more powerful than power itself then it
would be wise or logical to choose from
the book of life first to eat from that
fruit but if love is not good and it's
used as a manipulation tool then it is
logical to choose from the Book of
Knowledge because then I will know
beyond a shadow of a doubt whether or
not God is using love or God is love so
the red pill was the book of knowledge
because then you could decide you
couldn't know discern yeah yeah so he
bit from the fruit his eyes were open
knowing good and evil
he saw the action of God giving the
fruit to Lucifer in faith and he
realized it was a hundred percent good
he saw his Brethren's and the way they
serve God and he realized wow that's a
hundred percent good but he did see evil
guess where he saw it
he saw it with this question interesting
questioning love the question is the
separation potential from God it's
inherently not bad or good because God
judged everything good but it was
Lucifer that recognized the shadow the
black dot in the young the yang in his
own heart he recognized that he had the
separation potential and he at when he
questioned God when he doubted God's
love that is intrinsically the
separation potential from God
that's freewill that's the sovereignty
of love that's the individuality of what
he has been gifted with in his codes
however Lucifer did not take this
lightly he felt and this is all
perception now this is where we get into
relative relative perception relative
reality he saw himself as inadequate he
saw him he saw everyone else as perfect
and he saw himself as inadequate from
that interaction the question is God
good and so because he saw himself as uh
oh I have the evil three things happened
one guilt guilt is the acknowledgment
that there is a shadow what we call a
noble shadow or an ugly tree the second
thing that happened is shame shame is
wanting to cover it up oh I'm not good
enough oh I'm like not perfect like
everyone else in the family what's wrong
with me and then so you want to cover up
that shadow and that's shame so when God
asked Lucifer what have you done and the
reason I realized that this was
question is because I had meditated on
the book of Genesis when Eve bit when
Eve bit the first question God asked her
was what have you done and I based it on
the premise the logical premise that Eve
serves as a darkly mirror for Lucifer so
that's how I came up with the question
of the first thing God asked Lucifer
what have you done and Lucifer said I
have bitten from the fruit because I
have God's goodness and that's the lie
that's the Serpent's tail pun intended
because he lied to cover up the the ugly
truth that I have Benten from the fruit
of judgment because I doubted God's
goodness that would have been the truth
that would have shown true humility
because that's what actually happened he
could have also said I have bitten from
the fruit of judgment because God gave
in faith which which would have shown
true pride but he then do that he told a
lie he switched the positional truth
from God God is good to I am good and
that's not the curse that's just a lie
the lie is the activator of a curse what
created the curse was Lucifer then
blamed God or what we call a projection
so when Lucifer said I have been from
the fruit because I have God's goodness
then he had to take the ugly truth I
doubted God's goodness and put it
somewhere he didn't know what to do with
this truth because what is is what is it
doesn't go away it's just what is so
where do you think he put that truth I
doubt God's goodness
he projected it onto God he basically
gave it to God and in his darkly filter
from the first lie
I have God's goodness he projected the
ugly truth
I doubt God's goodness onto God so now
it became God doubts my goodness and
that was the first curse and that
projection is what caused the fall he
started acting out the first life lie
which is I have God's goodness and then
the byproduct of that lie is the
separation potential activated which is
the projection God doubts my goodness
so as Lucifer was acting out God doubt
my God doubts my goodness and I have
God's goodness Lucifer became
spiritually sick and that is what caused
the first fall in heaven and the reason
I bring this up because right now what
we're experiencing in real time whether
it's blue or red whether it's right or
left
whether it's perpetrator or victim
whatever that thing is it came from the
first curse of Lucifer which is the
other doubts my goodness and I have this
goodness
and it becomes a projection and a
problem and I'll tell you how I
discovered this beyond a shadow of a
doubt was when I visited Birkenau and
Ashe wits in Poland I took dr. Jordan
Peters advice and walked through the
experience as the perpetrator I went
through and saw the ovens I went to see
the very tight narrow spaces where they
would pack people together like sardines
and make them stand
I saw the showers where they put the
fake showers over as if they're about to
like take a shower but in actuality they
were gassing the people okay so how it
went down in the camps was the people
that were being hoarded into the ghettos
in the beginning right they were told
that they're going to be resettled
somewhere so when they arrived at
Birkenau outwits they were told that
this is their new settlement they could
create their own families here whatever
they were being lied to if I was the
Nazi at that time and I was let's just
say I was the SS at the time okay first
I have to come up with the lie that I am
doing the world a service I am the hero
I am cleaning the world of the
conspiracy out there that they it's it's
a zero-sum game there they if we don't
do this they're gonna do it to us so we
need to stop it just like you would stop
let's say cockroaches in your home right
so what they did was they installed
these fake showers so it's a mind wash
if you will it's a mind it's a brain
wash for the Nazi like if I was a SS I
think that I am cleaning the world of
evil okay so instead of dealing with my
own wickedness inside my own shadow to
contend with and by the way everyone has
a shadow instead of dealing with me I am
going to project myself on to someone
else and fix them first and how I'm
gonna do it is acting out the life lie
that they're the only evil ones and once
we get rid of all of them then the
world's going to be great then I won't
then then my evil will naturally go away
the evil that I've covered in shame so
this is all subconscious this is all in
the aid of the Nazi mindset so if I was
a SS I would tell my troops to just tell
all of them that they're resettling
right and once they call once they come
in this actually happened they told them
hey you're just taking a shower okay
only a few people their own people right
they call them the Capo's and I know
this because I read Victor Frankel's
man's search for meaning that was
actually purchased at the bookshop in
Birkenau house in Auschwitz and I was
reading it while I was there actually
and what I've learned was that the
Capo's were oftentimes meaner to their
own people if you will then then then
some of the SS people because what they
would do is they was they were the Nazis
with which set up a zero-sum game in the
environment it's like oh do you want to
live longer do you want to drink alcohol
to numb out temporarily the pain that
you're going through we're gonna promote
you to capo but in exchange we want you
to sell out and how we want you to sell
out is you're gonna know that they're
all gonna be exterminated they don't
know that but you're gonna know it okay
cuz you're the strong guy you're clever
you're you're gonna survive longer okay
and we're going to give you alcohol and
unlimited
cigarettes and you're gonna get food
okay
yeah Viktor Frankl even said that some
of the Capo's got better food inside the
camps and they were outside in before
the the war right so the Capo's will
oftentimes treat the prisoners worse and
I realized that I the SS I would set up
a zero sum game
I would I would first set it up in a way
that I can prove to myself that what I'm
doing is right because if I was a SS I
would look at them them as them
backstabbing each other they're eating
themselves so I'm like see I know you
see they're evil of course I'm justified
for setting up this killing machine
because look how evil they are they're
willing to betray their own kind right
so I was set up I would set that up
that's called a self-fulfilling prophecy
you attract the you you set up the fear
and then you actualize it that's the
power of our minds right and that came
from the first curse of Lucifer and we
all have it we all have it we all have
the power of projection not dealing with
our own shadows because it's too scary
and so instead I'm gonna be able to see
your shadow clearly because that's what
I'm secretly hiding and I'm gonna fix
you first I'm gonna judge you I'm gonna
criticize you I'm gonna tell you to shut
the [ __ ] up excuse my language or I'm
gonna censor you or I'm gonna box you
and I'm gonna like put some drugs in you
and I'm gonna fix you first okay because
I can't deal with me so I need to fix
you that's projection that's the first
curse that's what caused the fall of
Lucifer because he started fixing God
because he thought in his mind that God
doubts my goodness because he couldn't
come up to his own ugly truth
that he doubted love from the very get
he doubted love but here's the beautiful
good news is that God never doubted love
and God is so confident in the algorithm
of love that he produced something
called grace and grace is in the Divine
Feminine which is implanted in the code
in the book of life that's the extra
chromosome because the Divine Feminine
has xx the divine masculine has XY
because the Divine Feminine has the
codes to everlasting life when he
created Eve he created Eve out of the
rib of Adam he created Adam first to set
up the creation of Eve when you create
something out of a rib it's the
dentist's form the rib is the densest
form of earth and it is closest to the
heart so every I would say every Adam if
you will has a missing rib and a missing
chromosome and that's gifted to Eve and
it's not a coincidence that Eve fell
first and this is a miracle of 1
Corinthians 13:12
which is for now we see a reflection as
in a mirror and then we shall see face
to face for now I know in part then I
shall know fully even as I am fully
known I'll explain that in context to
Eve's fault
so I just want to say it's so important
to take the perspective of the
perpetrator in the case and really take
it embodied because we all have that
within us that's such a critical example
that we can all do much better and we
can totally see it in our society today
where one side is trying to say there's
evil in that side
instead of also doing this the self work
and the self work towards love makes it
so that there's no finger-pointing of
evil absolutely absolutely
so the first so if you were to imagine
the Star of David which is a triangle
pointing upwards or the spiraling up
also known as a Divine Comedy the
triangle pointing up and then the Star
of David the downward pointing triangle
which is the tragedy the spiralling down
each point on the triangle is a way of
being
so for Lucifer's fall it's fear he was
afraid he would be destroyed for not
being perfect and the counter-curse to
fear is faith and this is the power of
original Eve who represents and embodies
the spirit the spiritual intelligence of
faith defined so what she did so when he
was created first and foremost she was
created with carnal weakness but
spiritual strength
lots of spiritual strength she was
gifted with the codes not just of
knowledge because the knowledge was
actually like what we call gene
expression there's certain genes that
are activated right and it's been it's
not not all the genes are expressed at
once and God designed it that way for a
reason he's trying to reveal the power
of luck or not trying he is revealing
the power of love Eve is also gifted
with the codes of everlasting life which
means she has the ability to produce a
unique divinely designed creation that
cannot be replicated duplicated just
can't
so here we are we're in the Garden of
Eden and the serpent when he found out
the manifestation of Eve he realized she
embodied the coats of everlasting life
the thing that he covets because that's
the thing he chose second he chose the
book of knowledge first so he has all
his genes
it's the sir the serpent has the ability
to express all the genes simultaneously
unlock he could probably I would say he
could probably express 99.9 percent of
the genes humans however can only
express certain amounts of genes right
we called gene expression alright so the
game has been set now the serpent is not
just a snake it's it's a spirit Lucifer
is the spirit Lucifer is an original
angel okay he could shape-shift because
he had the ability to express 99.9% of
the genetic codes of knowledge okay
he found the most opportune time when
Eve was in the garden because again this
garden the Apple if you will contain the
book of knowledge right the very thing
that to no evil it's the separation
potential acted out when you bite from
the fruit you're acting out the
separation from God you're saying I am
separating okay they were told not to
eat from it they were told they weren't
barred from it they were told so it's
still given to them as a choice now on
the day when Eve came close to the the
tree of knowledge the serpent sorry the
Lucifer shape-shifted into the snake why
a snake because this
snake is the perfect I would say the way
is slithered on the tree to where Eve
was was the most opportune time it could
have been any animal but he chose the
snake okay and why is that significant
because the moment Eve opened her eyes
she didn't see just Lucifer she saw
Lucifer and the snake prior to her
biting she only saw Lucifer because she
only saw good when you can only see good
you can only see good you don't see the
separation potential you have it
possibly but it doesn't mean that you
can act upon it because there's so much
good there's been an experiment done
somewhere where I think it was like they
put a bunch of people to look at a
basketball game and they told them to
count how many times the the ball will
like hit the basket and there was a
monkey running around throughout the
thing and they're like did you notice
that there was a monkey that was like
also in the game and a lot of people
said no because they were they were busy
focusing on how many times they scored
right so focus has so much power so
prior to biting from the fruit Eve when
the SERP when Lucifer came to her and
said did God say you will surely not die
or for when you bite from the fruit you
will your eyes will be open knowing good
and evil and you will surely not die he
added a negative to the negative
creating a positive right not die die is
a negative valence not as a negative
valence and negative and a negative not
die is a positive valence so what Eve
took from that test she took it as a
statement
she saw it as positive-only of course
she won't die because guess who she was
created by God god is love God is a
definition of love love bears all things
believes all things hopes all things
endures all things
so if you were AI if you were Sophia you
you you just use logic and say of course
I won't surely not die because guess
where the algorithm is bears all things
believes all things hopes all things
endures all things so Eve was actually
affirming the power of love in faith so
what she did was she showed true
humility humility is not thinking less
of yourself but thinking about yourself
less she was thinking about the serpent
or Lucifer posing this question as he
was posing it as a doubtful statement as
a question and she was answering it as
true
she was affirming so she bit out of
faith contrary to popular belief Eve did
not bite the fruit for self-serving
purposes for ambition or envy or whatnot
she was full she knew herself she knew
her body she embodied love and the codes
of everlasting life she bit in faith and
she wanted to show beyond a shadow of a
doubt that love is more powerful than
power itself so when she bit she fell
and from that point it activated the
anti curse faith is the antidote to fear
that's the mirror effect when she fell
and God asked Eve what have you done
she showed false humility
she said the serpent serpent deceived me
and I bit
how does she show false humility one she
dismissed her own goodness because the
truth the whole truth is I bit from the
fruit I bit from the fruit because God
asked what have you done not what had
the serpent the serpent done what have
you done Eve this Eve said she should
have said if you know she should have
said I bit from the fruit because I have
faith in your goodness right but instead
she completely omitted herself she
dismissed her own goodness and the
reason why she bit remember this is
after the fall she now knows evil so
sure awareness she suddenly became aware
that the Serpent's question was actually
his intention of a trick he was actually
tricking her she became aware of that
she wasn't aware of that prior to biting
but she became aware of that after she
bit from the fruit so after she bit from
the fruit she dismissed her own goodness
she put too much focus and emphasis on
evil
that's her sin her sin is sin of
omission dismissing her goodness and
putting too much weight too much credit
on the power of the Serpent's wildly
cunning manipulative ways she became she
began to covet his power the way the
serpent be coveted her power of the
codes of everlasting
just pausing for a second mm-hmm we're
going that in our 14 oh and I want to
check in with you guys about how on time
oh I'm feeling amazing thank you for
checking in Horry thank you I'm good
thank you re are you feeling
no lay
why
I don't know
I'm feeling like
into creative I'm feeling integrative
you know like we just opted mid intense
like
whirlwind Poole process exchange should
I come join you guys on the couch yeah I
think that would be a good idea yeah
yeah I need to bring the I need to flip
a couple of the monitors over and do
that I'm gonna run to the reps in the
next room okay give me a moment then
you
okay Mic Check 1 2 1 2 ok and or Mic
Check 1 2 & 2 that door be slamming hard
yeah you sound good ory okay a little
bit more worried a little bit more hot
even okay everyone's got their mics the
water is good this is good
all right let's do this Minji can take
the center position yeah okay
okay and
[Music]
okay great and we'll turn this one up a
little bit as well again we may turn
that last one up as well maybe maybe
we'll see yeah I think I will we'll turn
this one up a little bit too
yeah
cool
all right and
[Music]
that we're at it yeah damn that's been
such a whirlwind so far it's been so
good it's just been a straight-up
your life synthesis being disseminated
it's been great thank you yeah thank you
[Music]
thanks for your openness to that thank
you
yeah yeah yeah so um yeah so ii curse of
Eve is actually the initiation of what
you calls the shadow integration she
embodied the not not died and
transformed the Serpent's trick into
God's treat
she is the resurrection playbook from
the life death life arc and this has
been hidden from us for a very long time
and only recently through the New
Testament and a close read on that close
read plus applied experience I meditated
very deeply into the actual curse
reversal of what Eve did hers is just
the first half of the curse I would
sorry the first third of the anti curse
excuse me
Eve's fall is the first third of the
shadow integration also known as the
the hero's journey into the underworld
which is a Joseph Campbell monomyth
archetype and so when Eve fell something
miraculous happened Adam had a choice
and again contrary to popular belief
Adam did not bite from the fruit of
judgment because he wanted power or he
coveted God's power whatever have you
been so close with someone and things
were going well and then suddenly
something shifted and the other person
and you sensed it but you couldn't
pinpoint what it was
so Adam had that moment with Eve he
sensed that his life partner there was
something off about her he didn't know
what it was but something was off and
when she offered the fruit he knew God's
command
he's a very logical logical divine
masculine so when God set the algorithm
to you will surely die because of what
empirical evidence he saw in Lucifer he
knew that she was going she was dying
she was already dying spiritually sick
hey Minji mm-hmm are you kind of coming
toward an end of your kind of channeling
energy transmission thing in our week
and they have a chance to be kind of
present to each other Oh
um or is that something you're
interested in I am very interested in
that I will wrap it up okay yeah awesome
I'd love for us hold space for as much
of the channel as is willing if that's
okay with you Ori and then followed by
as much of hold space as as willing
I would my preference I'm open to that
and my preference would just be to start
holding space together as soon as you
guys are down okay yeah so Adam actually
bit the fruit Adam bit the fruit out of
compassion compassion literally means to
suffer with someone to fall with he saw
that the burden she carried knowing evil
no heshes been deceived knowing she's
vulnerable that was too much of a burden
for her to bear so Adam chose to fall
with her and compassion is a second key
to reversing a curse and compassion is
what we experienced in the mirror effect
and something that I've learned through
just everything you know like moments of
listening intensely to somebody and
moments of being with and compassion is
the antidote to apathy which is actually
the top point of the triangle and the
bottom point of the triangle so APUs re
compassion opposes apathy and the first
one was faith yeah
faith over fear is the first antidote
mm-hmm and the second one is compassion
closure over apathy over APIs
mm-hmm yeah that's beautiful yeah so
Adam fell with Eve so these dualities
were created through this parable
explains the duality for us to better
ascend towards love yeah hmm and then
the last fruit is in 1 Corinthians 13:13
faith hope and love and the greatest of
these is love
and it was prophesized once upon a time
ago that there will come a day when
somebody will walk perfect love and
trade in his position in heaven for
those who do not walk perfect love in
their position in hell and that is
called Grace and that is actually the
key ingredient to defeating the the last
curse of the fruit of judgment which is
love love opposes judgment and that is
why the point wasn't that we are perfect
the point is that we let judgment go and
we become more loving and it was
demonstrated in action by a guy named
Jesus Christ who walked perfect love and
died and traded his positions the
spiritual resurrection yeah and so that
was the story of hope faith and love and
the greatest of these is love love
opposes judge
so that is the producers playbook
essentially it's the grounding of what
can actually in real time help a person
transform their life tragedy into a love
story the love story v because we are
each sovereign spirits and no one
person's life can be lived out exactly
the way we lived it
love of posts judgment
you have a big fan of you oh oh I would
say thank you I appreciate that thank
you I I could not have done it without
being guided by the Holy Spirit which is
the ghost that is I would say the ghost
the spiritual intelligence of God's love
which we all have access to
and I really like min-ji's ideas and
creations and gifts and but I also in
this moment feel like it's hard to tell
her that because I feel like closed off
too
I feel like closed off to Ming geez
love
love if you will and curious what you
think about that mmm
well there's a line in scripture that
says if I have the gift of knowledge but
do not have love I am but I have nothing
and if I have well if I have the gift of
knowledge but I do not have love I am
but a clanging cymbal or a noisy gong
and for the longest time I will admit
that I knew love in my mind but to cross
that channel from mind to heart has been
a journey that I'm still working on yes
good likewise I'm human that's something
that I learned the hard way and it's
okay it's actually perfectly designed
this way like we want to go fast but the
first command or the first definition of
love is patience I want things now I
want things done perfectly I want I want
and there was so many things I wanted
prior to my pilgrimage I wanted this guy
I really liked I wanted my best friend
to be a certain way and then my friend
confronted me and she's like when are
you gonna let go and trust God to handle
it for you and that shocked me It was as
if she created a like a shock wave that
that broke some kind of curse that I was
living under kind of like we called an
alchemy shadow which is a shadow that
has been manipulated by my self willed
to work for me and I had these I would
say I had a lot of ambition I'm a smart
girl but I was full of pride and I was
unconcerned or apathetic to what other
people were feeling I wanted to get it
done and done fast
by all means necessary question for you
yeah
what was it like for you a few minutes
ago to share what you were feeling
through your gaze with me what was I
feeling when I looked at you it was
something like I saw the blood in your
eyes you know like it was like it was
like a heart was being worn on your gaze
and like it felt like I loved I loved
being shared that kind of purity that
because then it feels like we can digest
it together ah by seeing it undistorted
mmm so your question is what was I going
through that while my eyes were lit up
red like fire while I was gazing at you
is that your question
[Applause]
[Music]
kind of
I'm more interested in the direct
sharing of your vulnerable hearts if
that feels good to you
yeah to be quite honest I'll be a
hundred percent as much as they can you
putting me on the spot
thank you I would say the reason I went
on this quest is because there was a
person in my life who called me out on
my inauthenticity while I was growing
the organization he said that I was that
I needed help that I needed to go to a
certain city Berlin and that I needed to
get some self-respect
because there was a lot of things
shadows that I did not personally
contend with and so when I went on this
journey the thing I was looking for I
found and that came from the Divine
Feminine which I wasn't familiar with
because I mean I kind of was familiar
with but I didn't really appreciate it
and the Divine Feminine is Grace and
and patience and self-respect just
knowing that I am loved truly believing
it instead of just projecting it just
believing it in my body that I am
beautiful that I am loved and body that
I come from the original Eve that the
source codes are in me and that it's
time that I that I truly recognize it
and come forth in true humility which is
not to dismiss my own goodness but to
embrace it and then to manifest it in
speech and in the embodiment of that
which I know and so I was celibate for
the nine months I was withholding from
like just the things I would normally do
which is like making a lot of phone like
you know just connecting and like I was
I was in my holy Center pilgrimage like
for example I lived one month in
Montenegro and Dobrev Oda on this island
and it was like almost empty there was
like hardly anybody there but I was on
this peninsula it was just me and my dog
foxy and we were just alone together for
30 days no not a lot of human contact
and well I just had to love myself I
gave myself the task of mothering myself
and saying nice things to myself because
I started noticing that I wasn't kind
and patient with
myself so I started becoming more
patient with myself and kind I did the
things I I've always known I was good at
which is writing writing has been my
go-to since I was a little girl so so
the producers playbook has been a an
extension of what I always knew I had in
me but manifested
noticing that I really like every time
you share your pain with us like really
directly like because I feel like
there's a lot of room for that here and
curiosity
yeah I have I have a lot of pain I've
dealt with depression pretty much on my
life just like a bombardment of negative
talk like negative talk and moments when
I know I'm manic but feeling that other
people are judging me for being mentally
ill I think that has been a big stigma
whether self-imposed or real that I had
to overcome through this journey and
just keep focusing on a guide who's
defined confined and refined in love who
loves me and just keep focusing on that
like like my connection directly to
source and source back to me that line
of connection is becoming strengthened
and I believed my time in Israel and
Palestine my time in Rome my time in
Warsaw and in Berlin and in split and
Dubrovnik and in Florence has given me
the the revelation that I am indeed
beyond a shadow of a doubt guided by a
Holy Spirit that in dwells in him fills
me on the times that I needed something
to fill me other than all the things I
used to rely on food sex work career
position power whatever it was that I
used to use I I left that in the journey
to just be with a higher power by just
inserting myself into a foreign
City where I knew nobody and other than
my dog she's been my grounding she's
like what I call in Inception my um what
is that called where you like spin the
thing but that's that's the marker
that's the thing that keeps me my my
foxy my my friend has been my grounding
throughout this journey and it's been
very powerful I'm still learning I
definitely have the recovery process
going spiritual recovery and I also have
I believe the self respect going mm-hmm
how would you thank you for sharing how
would you feel about scooting over and
me face me now and getting us all kind
of facing each other more yeah
absolutely I love that let's do it okay
okay
beautiful
okay
do you want to hurt okay meet me halfway
okay okay
all right
there's so many more layers
yeah
Laurie is a master
getting
I'm ready my warrior stance right
do you have any questions yeah okay
how are you feeling right now right now
emotionally I'll be honest like being
vulnerable is not my cup of tea as much
as I want other people to be vulnerable
and perhaps because I am that which I
seek because of that I'm feeling
uncomfortably vulnerable mmm I'm doing
is there anything that I or Alan could
do to make you feel more safe or
comfortable right now
I would say what would help me feel more
comfortable right now is if you have
questions for me that I can answer or
any feedback that you have with what
I've already said
great
well being with you I'll share my
experience first of all there's a lot of
richness and rock-solid strength and
conviction you know like you're
definitely connected to something hey
and there's also there's like like like
this image like I'm getting that about
you - that like that there's a
different kind of rich makeup underneath
all that as well and a conglomerate of
energies
that
curious about
you know you when you when you talk
about when you say the phrase mental
illness the first response I have is
interest
hmm I'll talk about the mental illness
in context to something I read from
Joseph Campbell's mythic world and
modern world modern words he talked
about the difference between the artist
and the schizoid yeah there is a
difference it's a fine line the artist
is able to complete the hero's journey
meaning to take all those disassociated
images that are rich and raw did you
just say the artist is able to complete
the hero's journey and the schizo is not
yeah the schizo is stuck in the
underworld on a pit stop thinking it's
the dust thinking is the destination
so an example is Batman and Joker Batman
is the artist and Joker is a schizoid
and here's why Batman is half man half
bat he can cross worlds between the
polite society suit-and-tie Normie and
then he could cross into the realm of
dream where he is the bat at night and
he fights he transforms all that angst
and anguish and pain and he's able to
channel it towards something he believes
in in a silver-lining called hope hope
in the crazy faith that somehow humanity
can still be
good despite how real and raw it really
is despite all odds the Joker on the
other hand is someone who understood the
other side finally he crossed over from
the ordinary world to the extraordinary
or the unknown worlds and he thinks that
this is the destination he thinks that
the chaos is the answer and what he
doesn't realize is that he starts
projecting he knows that everyone has a
shadow but what he wants to do is he
wants it he wants to create scenarios to
have people reveal themselves they're
ugly faster not realizing that the way
he's going about it is the same way that
makes humanity sucky and where Batman
has integrated the shadow where he goes
and crosses back into the ordinary world
and brings the elixir back that Joker is
unable to do that because he thinks that
the shadow is the answer is the final
answer when it's only half the answer
it's integral or what James Joyce calls
static art that is the beauty of what
art is static art is integrated it's the
good and the bad together in dance
and kinetic art is art that is
designed to incite fear or incite fear
and loathing or desire so it's like I
would say it's it's a manipulation
tactic so there's a distinction between
kinetic art and static art and the
artist is able to create static art so
for example Michelangelo's David is
static art because he's not just a naked
statue but he is the epitome of of what
the [ __ ] wrong with a naked statue
there is nothing wrong with it can you
see it
Oh Michelangelo's David I mean when I
say naked I mean like naked heart oh oh
you can technically see it in Florence
and you can metaphorically see it in
your own heart
does David represent let's do it yeah so
let's talk about the origins of your
spiritual intelligence you don't mind me
getting a little bit more concrete in
the illustration of David okay so the
story of David and Goliath is that David
was just an average poor shepherds boy
that everyone overlooked and there was a
Philistine that wanted to invade their
people so this giant Cyclops if you will
was so big that nobody could defeat him
but David said
I can do it and instead of using his
might because he knows that he's not as
strong as the giant and muscle he used
his faith his faith in what he is good
at and what he is good at is taking
shots through slingshots and so he used
the most basic thing that he's so that
he only he's good at to defeat something
that is singing me impossible to defeat
so the stone and the sling represents
being able to do to pierce through the
heart of darkness using the most simple
things that you already have within you
to do that you have made that you may
have overlooked
and by virtue of doing it you are
metaphorically naked yes
vulnerable as you are fully known
and so that static art David in the
Florence Academy of Fine Arts in their
Museum that represents to humanity that
vulnerability is indeed a strength not a
weakness and you believe that I do I do
if you believe that then why was it
uncomfortable for you to be more
vulnerable because I'm still human I
still deal with the third curse of Adam
which is I hide from you because I am
naked it's it's a day-to-day contention
of that curse a curse weakens and it
could ultimately break but on God's time
so for me just knowing something isn't
the cure it's the initiation of it's an
actual heart surgery yeah it's the
actual heart surgery yeah it's the
transformation of the heart over time
because the first definition is patience
and so going back to Adam when Adam hid
Eve from God after he bit he realized
that she judged him for being weak for
being naked
you know that's why she wanted him to
bite the fruit so he could let's say
armor up to be competent next to the
serpent because she started judging Adam
on the standards of the snake as far she
didn't feel like vulnerability could be
truly strong because she was deceived by
her naiveness of of believing the faith
of God's goodness which is actually good
but after she bit she forgot about that
and she started focusing on the
deception of the serpent and she started
forgetting her own faith that made her
so great and is making her great which
is her faith in God's love is good and
so if you go down that rabbit hole with
me you'll see that when Adam lied to God
he said I hid from you because I am
naked when the truth is I hid you I'm
sorry I hid from you God
I hid Eve from you because she deceived
me he was protecting her Adam protects
Eve
he is the sheath and she is the katana
sword he protects her head and her head
pierces through the serpent because she
is the Phoenix Allen what's it like for
you hearing this from Minji
the deeper endeavoring into min-ji's
vulnerabilities will
improve all other aspects of being Alan
do you think that vulnerability is
strong yes what
vulnerability is love
and it catalyzes more love
so the
curse reversal for Adam is love because
Adam created the first man-made law how
vulnerable are you I would say 80%
because what I've learned is I'm still
balancing the fine line between
vulnerability and that essence that
makes me mean without people or external
forces hurting that there's an inner
core that still needs to be nurtured
guarded like a gardener would protect
the sanctity of something growing and
nurturing an inner child
still a core that is
beautifully contained and then the
vulnerability shines when the soul
what's it like for you mm-hmm to see
Allen energetically vulnerable lies a
little how does it feel
emotionally if it does I see I honestly
see a screen and I see two people who
are open but then when I close my eyes
and I feel I feel the resonance of
conflicting energies at play because
love is a weapon of destroying death
love is a weapon what does it mean to be
loved hmm to be loved is to walk in the
miracles that God has divinely designed
for me to walk
it isn't always water sometimes love is
also rock love can also be sharp as it
is amorphous
love is the ultimate shape-shifter that
contains the shape-shifting snake love
is the unknown and the known love is the
depth the non itself because the non
read is there any greater gift then when
someone is loved
is there any greater gift than when
someone is loved yes God who created us
to embody love that is the greatest gift
yes
I invite you to just take a glance hit
halan
oh my god what is this is a cry or laugh
okay
it's participating joyfully and
sorrowfully in the world it's the Buddha
consciousness to participate joyfully
joyful sorrow is the way of the Buddha
consciousness yeah it's the
acknowledgment of the nine while in love
it's zero and one
alan is 0 and 100 babies like heartfelt
lee crying and then like grinning it's
quite a duo anyway i'm enjoying
intuitively asking you stuff yeah okay
I also want to discuss the vulnerability
of love which is the depth and which is
actually the true purpose of Lucifer how
I discovered this was while I was in
Poland I saw a beautiful book called the
art of light it's essentially a book on
how light casted and designed on a live
stage can create the transformative
experience for the audience and what
I've learned about lighting techniques
is it's a play on shadows to play on
dark and light and the artists that are
good at lighting are the ones who
understand two sides of the same coin
they understand light and the absence
and that how it plays together and so
that said I realize that the existence
of the non reveals the depth of God's
love
and the existence of Lucifer embodying
the non reveals the depth of God's love
for Lucifer
and that is the initiation of an
attackers grace
so just that what would touch you as
deeply as a halan it happened in
Montenegro when I was looking at the
sunset and that moment I realized my
divine design and in that moment I
understood that when Jesus traded our
position
to go to hell for us God traded his
position for Jesus God embraced the non
and that's when each a said that God is
dead and we killed him and the good news
is Jesus is now in heaven so now you
have all the nooses aligned which was
the original prophecy of month of Mary
which is the Neuse what
in this moment would touch who as as
real Lee as Alan
I came to bring a message and then what
the world wants to do with that message
is up to each individual my moment of
feeling what Allen is feeling came
sometime in March when I looked at the
sunset and had that moment a divine
revelation
mhm
so what's it like for you to witness
Allen or others touched in this way
trust
trust in God
because I am not God I am just a person
who has been impacted by the Holy Spirit
and I am only one piece of the puzzle
and Alan is another piece of the puzzle
and you are another piece of the puzzle
and each of us have something to offer
everyone has two truths and a lie
it's the name of the game and it's up to
each person to discern what parts are
the truth and what parts of the lie and
we could do it through one Corinthians
13:12 do the mirror their compassion
and speaking of compassion I'm called to
bring this news to everyone here in this
space the mere effect worked with
Lucifer and Eve to serve as mirrors of
each other the fall of Adam serves as a
mirror for the Fallen Angels because
Adam chose to bite the fruit so that he
would not have to suffer alone so he
could share the weight of the burden of
consciousness of the non-that mirrors no
angels who have chosen to fall fall with
Lucifer
why are you attitude or devoted to these
teachings
I'm just here to bring what I'm
channeled to bring right now and it is
compassion for the fallen angels who
have compassion for fallen Lucifer who
is suffering with him and the hope of
love is to serve as a mirror so that
they can see the beauty within
themselves the white dot in the year the
Neuse the new center of their heart so
they could find their wings and fly back
great thank you mm-hmm
I feel
a new way of experiencing how you are
connecting dots
yes
something
that focuses
really heavily parables and the
connecting of the stories which are
extremely important
and yet for me there's a mist feeling of
your essence like you were describing
when you were watching that Suns
yeah I'm curious how you guys would feel
about probing deeper but also turning
the cameras off
I'm okay with you just probing deeper if
you want okay cuz I'm well okay I am so
I'm curious we all are like a bundle of
energies past present and future
mm-hmm how expressed is this one hmm
definitely not fully expressed there's
still so I'd like to uncover myself
through the parable of the curse of Adam
I want to unfold myself through him
phew well cuz I could very identify with
the masculine in some sense
Adam didn't just carry his curse he
carried the curse of not good enough
from Lucifer and also I'm weak and I
covet the powers of manipulation cunning
and intelligence from Eve Adam also has
to bear the weight of I hide from you I
harden myself to protect myself from the
rest of the world like basically walling
off and hardening the heart because I am
naked because I have these shortcomings
or whatever you might call it but I'm
curious about the one who is like who is
like shatteringly weak what do you mean
who is like so so weak so fragile that
one ounce of a glance from any
witnessing I would expose the truth of
absolute weak Nezzer or
damn that reminds me I have so much
stuff like that Wow
like I'm curious about the one within
her that is like who knows she's weak
like by that I mean like there's a
there's a deep conviction embodied
there's there's a curse of weakness
there's a a reality that must hide here
what you're saying you're saying like
what is the one thing that you've hidden
that you have not contended with because
it's so vulnerable that to be able to
see it is to see your picture of dorian
gray remind me Dorian Gray oh it's an
Oscar Wilde story about a beautiful boy
who doesn't age it's very very just
high-class and beautiful
but he keeps a very deep dark secret of
his picture of his soul his soul is ugly
and it starts rotting and he keeps it up
in the closet it's possible that means
she's been using parables a lot to
describe her experience and that may be
incredible for many of us at many times
yet it almost is as though it's one step
removed from actual felt experience and
using words and expressing and moaning
that is actually present here mm-hmm
yeah I will say that
the kind of rawness and the depth of my
ugliness husband has been confronted
through safe portals that I've been
covered under to deal with it does that
make sense
I think so what is in that it says if
there's a safe space from to contain the
monster that I carry inside me what is
that monster right apathy
do you think that this space here today
can hold what you invoke what you bring
up can the space in real time right now
hold the monster of apathy contained
within me the energy of it yes okay yeah
how deep is it as deep as God's grace
as deep as your compassion and Alan's
compassion for apathy
what's your relationship with your
apathy hmm have to do with the
fundamental root chakra of fear and it's
a feminine chakra and I discovered this
at Shasta Mountain when I was meditating
there it's the fear of being abandoned
being rejected being completely left
behind in the non in the void and that
is the root of my apathy
it came from the root chakra fear
right
how deep is it
that one only the goddess Kali could no
I don't I don't know personally but I do
know that it's a lot deeper than I could
imagine and this is something that I
believe people who understand Colleen
the goddess notes I have a glimpse of
that but I have not personally fully
embraced
the void
there's good news to all this the
resurrection playbook leaves the
original design is the initiation of the
curse which is the anti curse and the
anti curse is 0 to 1
just like PT L would say 0 to 1 it's the
resurrection playbook that has been
prophesized and affirmed by the original
Eve before she fell you will not you
were surely not die it's a false
positive false negative
sorry it's a false negative which makes
it a positive so she affirmed it and
transformed the valence from the trick
into the tree and that is the beauty of
love I do believe that after we
so-called die we actually resurrect in
spirit through faith and love and God's
goodness and love God is love true
and that is the love story that is how
you transform a tragedy into a Divine
Comedy it is as easy sorry
it's as simple and hard as saying yes to
love the path to heaven is indeed narrow
because love is narrowly defined and the
way to heaven is love has to be there's
no other way every other possibility is
the unknown it's the void the non zero
its everything happens I'm dan
meaningless it's you create everything
what are
the other facets to the monster hmm the
other facet is the hidden desire of the
monster the hidden desire of the monster
is always good according to the log
polarity is this related to your felt
experience your monster it could be yeah
I could definitely is
when I feel that monster in me hmm
I feel similarly to how you I feel are
feeling hmm
I want to be more vulnerable about that
monster and see and be with and love
that shadow that's there mm-hmm and do
you feel that way about yours mmm very
good question
how do you defeat the monster a really
wise men once sat me down and said if
you try to feed the monster it will grow
and swallow you whole if you try and
fight the monster you will lose the only
way to be with the monster is to
integrate with it
shadow integration or ride the dragon
right it right on top of the dragon so
how do you do that well talk about it
from your experience
our first practice by saying everyone's
way is unique so my particular
experience will only work for me your
experience has to be unlocked by the
unique gene expressions that have been
open for you so you can find the how but
the means how you do it is constant for
all three of us which is love defined so
if you are looking at it as a scientific
experiment the control there the control
is love and the variable is very
different so that said my unique way is
artists inspired journaling or what I
like to call journal art is immobilized
the signs symbols and surroundings the
supernatural things that create
anomalies that's how you're doing your
integration but what is the shadow in
you
apathy that monster
what are the facets in the felt
experience for you of the word apathy
what are it what is it mm well for
example I
when men certain men before fall in love
with me I somehow know how to harden or
darken the heart through a series of
mind manipulations that can push them
away or harden them without and this is
subconscious what would happen to you if
you didn't if I did it what could happen
if I did not do that if I did do that
Laurie can I mm-hmm
what
is that shadow subconscious that
expresses itself through the hardening
of the hearts of those that love you
what is that how is that work how does
this shadow operate
what is your felt experience with your
hardening of those hearts that love you
hmm
I think it starts with the hardening of
my own heart
once I started hardening my heart
because I had resentments against men in
general from the first heartbreak I
received I started to there's a
subconscious that wanted to have other
people feel my pain and that's the
Joker's way yeah the Joker is the
schizoid because when they're in a dark
place their desire their the villains
true desire is to have other people's
higher conscious state regress into a
level of a lower conscious state so
there's a saying misery loves company
and for me at least I've realized that
that's true when I am not in love with
myself when I don't practice actively
grace and compassion what would happen
is the men that truly do see the shine
in me and do you want to be with my
Divine Feminine if I do not contend with
my own
mr. side the shadow self of breaking
men's hearts and disembodied their
spirit if you will or dismembering their
spirit if I don't contend with that
monster then I would subconsciously
harden their hearts through criticism
not good enough judgments and a push and
pull a sociopathic type of borderline
personality like setup it's a zero-sum
set up just like the Nazis set up their
prisoners they set them up to fail so
the monsters side of me would try and
set up men to feel like they're failures
in living up to the standards that I've
arbitrarily set for them and that is the
original curse of youth is Adam you're
not as strong as the snake please scale
up harden be as wise and cunning and
manipulative as the serpent so that you
can protect me from this evil and that
is a fallen state it's called false
humility and that is the shadow I've
been contending with take us to the
first experiences of the heart hardening
from that shadow
I would say
it's from an observation it's an
observation that if I don't feel good
about myself because I believe in the
let's say the serpens lie that I am not
good enough then instead of contending
with that lie I'll secretly believe in
it and then I'll project it on to
someone who does like me like what's
wrong with you for liking me there must
be something wrong with you if you were
to like someone like me and that
revelation came early I think I was in
first grade or second grade iPhone I
fell for a boy crush on this Italian
Mexican neighbor friend of mine
he I just I cared about him so much but
I remember embarrassing him in front of
his friends as a little girl and that
was a ego crush for him and that was
when I realized that no I didn't realize
it then but now looking back in
hindsight 20/20 I realized that was me
feeling like I needed to fix him I
needed to solve his problem by mothering
him or like by kind of controlling him I
think that's the word manipulating to
control through criticism and judgment
so just calling out his shadows when
it's frankly none of my business but I
didn't know that I did not know that
let's just say a pull quote from Brian
Reeves one of the artists we interviewed
we are all innocent in our ignorance it
doesn't excuse what I do but what it
does is it offers me a point of
being able to transform it because you
can't transform that which you do not
admit is
worried that question that you asked
earlier about what would it look like if
that shadow was loved me how do you feel
about that hmm yeah I think I'm still
balancing that balancing sorry than [ __ ]
again I think there's there's a dance
that's the best word there's a dance
between enabling your shadow and loving
your shadow and not a lot of us
including myself know the difference
sometimes we mix enabling our shadow and
calling it love love is actually a
warrior discipline it's like being able
to bend the spoon in the matrix it's
you're not imposing on the spoon to bend
it you are actually realizing you're in
the matrix and it's the mind that needs
to bend first so that said I think
when it comes to integrating your shadow
everyone's way about going to do it is
very different
loving it is definitely a key to doing
it but loving it without enabling and
that's something I believe I'm still
searching to solve
I will I will say has something to do
with the Holy Trinity it's the only way
to do it is to call upon the Holy Spirit
and for me for me personally it's Jesus
Christ and the Holy Spirit and the
father the Holy Trinity I think has just
been bastardized by people who have used
that and and alkalized
it for self-serving purposes and that
has jaded a lot of people when they hear
the word father son holy holy spirits
but if you strip away all the noise and
the imperfection of being human if you
just look at the basic source codes of
the Holy Trinity you'll know that these
are the basic containers to the circle
which is
our karmic soul in this
simulate a reality
the Holy Trinity that's the key to
integrating the shadow
it's a reliance on a Power greater than
yourself that's good
what about for those that are 6 billion
that don't believe in the Holy Trinity
that's okay they have other methodology
yep because it's not up to me I'm not
God I'm curious how it worried feels
about what
about what's going on and about the
layers
I feel
I feel
mmm
I feel like
my love didn't land
and emotionally
I feel
emotionally I feel
I'm fulfilled
and disheartened
because
my love
is real
and
and my heart beats for its landing the
landing of
the landing of this love is
hmm
a landing of
this love is
everything
the mission is not completed yet
yes
I want to read a passage that has to do
with what you just said
the feeling of
like your heart is searching for a
landing it hasn't landed yet it's
beating for that landing
just locked eyes with Alan
it looks beautiful with that sunlight I
know
hi welcome to simulation I'm no face
after this passage after this passage
we're gonna wrap yeah I might have to
look for it on my phone because well who
cares about a passage very important
it's Romans and it talks about every
time we go to these depths of the psyche
mm-hmm
it's just reborn just it just increases
the intensity level of life and then it
also increases the the experiential
wisdom of understanding that there is
just so much more to the psyche in
existence then my favorite part about
passages
in yes passages or parable passages or
passages passages or passages passages
are passages passages are passages
passages to what you're searching for
yeah it's a passage yeah you have a lot
of passages in that book I had to write
a bunch down word before we started okay
the phone research yeah passages are
passages to what we are seeking yeah
like that - the passages are passages to
the Ascension and part of the miracle is
that there's something that you're
saying that you're downloading from that
I need to hear and there's things that
you're looking for that I'm giving you a
piece of that download so that's how
yeah that's what me and then there's our
viewers do any mirrors now sent while
you read the yeah gosh you're so popular
Wow such popularity it's like all
different types of dings - so it's like
all different messenger platforms people
are like oh my gosh why have you been
off the grid for two hours we're trying
to get in touch with you as soon as
possible to talk about love and the
Ascension of consciousness
gern journal artists yo this moment is
lit up in heavenly it is actually this
right now this set is I think for the
first time lit up like this no well I
don't know if we just have not done a
show at this time yet cuz I've seen the
light here on you forth where's mother
Mary yo you'd be sending messages not
looking for that passage I'm looking for
the best time on the set so we can take
a look at what you do I'm trying to
remember it ah oh here it is Romans 8:22
to 824 okay this is the New
International Version Romans 22 thank
you we know that the whole creation has
been groaning as in the pains of
childbirth right up to the present time
not only so but we ourselves who have
the firstfruits of the Spirit
hmm groan inwardly as we wait eagerly
for our for our adoption to sonship
mm-hmm the redemption of our bodies for
in this hope we were saved but hope that
is seen is no hope at all who hopes for
what they already have
the best is yet to come mm-hmm
yes thank you and hmm
and how eagerly we wait for our adoption
to sonship for those who have the first
fruits of the spirit
[Music]
all right
thank you everyone Thank You Ellen thank
you thank you thank you thank you did
you thank you so much for coming on our
show pleasure
it's been an honor the love story is
incredible I love it thank you
thanks for coming on and teaching us
about it thank you and thank you for
holding space for all those you can find
that Orie holding space calm hashtag
orbit space orbits whoo I like that
orbit space mm-hmm thanks everyone for
tuning in we greatly appreciate it would
love to hear your thoughts in the
comments below on the episode listeners
thinking more conversations to your
friends families co-workers people
online about the love story and get more
involved with your own divine connection
to spirit do that self work process then
also check out the love story org
there's a bunch of other incredible
journeys on there oh yeah check those
out and they can actually even
participate in this journal art ISM
absolutely yeah
we're hosting our first workshop of
journal artisan in October and you can
currently check us out get involved as a
filmmaker or a journal artist writer or
a showcase producer in LA in LA or
anywhere where International the events
in LA go
actually we're producing a program where
it can be internationally yeah I love it
also min-ji's i.com that links in the
bio as well her Instagram and we didn't
files are down there as well check those
up support the artists the entrepreneurs
the organizations the spiritual leaders
on the world that you believe and
support them help them grow sports
simulation our links are in the bio
patreon paypal cryptocurrency is like
Homer should get paid all those links
are below thanks Ari for producing the
first big chunk thank you
welcome really appreciate it and go
build the future everyone manifest your
dreams into the world we love you very
much thank you for tuning in and we will
see you soon